mais juste pour préciser une chose par
rapport aux dépenses il faut bien s'il
faut bien savoir une chose c'est que on
a une croissance de la masse salariale
dans les communes depuis 25 ans il ya eu
certes un transfert de compétences de la
part de l'état au niveau des communes au
fond au niveau des niveaux infra et
notamment au niveau des communes mais
savez-vous que 60% des hausses de
dépenses des communes sont liées à des
décisions communales pas des décisions
de l'état
c'est pas parce qu'on a revalorisé le
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires qui
pèse pour 40% dans la hausse de la masse
salariale dans les communes en vérité la
ou les
la principale explication pour 60% des
hausses des dépenses de personnel c'est
les journées du maire qui sont rajoutés
c'est les augmentations les primes au
niveau local et c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya du grain à moudre
au niveau communal pour faire des
économies
parce que vous avez dans une ville comme
montpellier ou toulouse
vous avez des gens qui travaillent moins
de 35 heures par semaine qui ont des
semaines à rallonge de congés payés en
plus offert par les municipalités qui
font qu'il ya vraiment un niveau de
dépense qui est beaucoup plus élevé par
rapport à la moyenne et donc les
économies elles sont avant tout la z